welcome to this presentation
my name is alexander lindemayer from the
university of cream
and this is a joint work with nicole
migo and petronsimo
and the goal of this presentation is to
give you an idea on how we can
improve a very classic online algorithm
for a very fundamental online problem
using machine learning predictions
so first let me introduce
the problem which is the k-server
problem on a line
so yeah let's imagine we have given some
real line
then the first part of
our of the input of our problem is a
sequence of n requests of points of on
this line
and the second part is a initial server
configuration which we denote by c0 and
which
tells us where our
case servers are located in the
beginning and yeah we write this as a k
tuple
so in this example we've given five
requests
and our initial configuration is dt
which means that we have two servers
located at d
now the goal is to move the servers um
in a way such that they serve
the requests in the order they appear in
this sequence
so for example in this example instance
we may move once or from d to c for the
first request
then this server further to the second
request to a
and for the first third requested b
um we move the other server which is
select d
and we then end up
after serving three requests in the
configuration a b
and the objective is to minimize the
total travel distance of the servers
and due to this objective we will also
assume
that the servers are always ordered by
the position on the line on
these configuration tuples because it
makes no it
makes no sense to move one server by
another yes
so
yeah if we know the sequence of requests
in advance
and this is called offline setting and
there exists um
efficient algorithms to solve this
problem optimally
hence
we will look at the more interesting
online setting in the online setting and
on an algorithm learns about the
sequence of requests one by one
so at any point in time it only knows
the current locations of its servers and
the current request it has to solve
and only if it serves the current
request it gets to know the next request
or learns that various
no more requests
and here we use competitive analysis to
analyze the performance of an online
algorithm
where we say that an eyebrow is either
competitive if its costs are at most um
alpha times the cost of an optimal
solution for the instance
where the optimal resolution
refers to the optimal offline solution
and plus some
additive consensus which is only allowed
to depend on the initial configuration
and this has to hold for all instances
so let me give you some known results
so online there's the classic and neat
algorithm called double coverage
which is um fake competitive for having
k servers
and it works as follows
and whenever a newer request arrives it
moves the at most two closest servers
of the request towards it with the same
speed
and
when one server reaches the request both
servers stop which means that both
servers will move the same distance and
the closer server will eventually start
to be pressed
and
yeah one can show for any metric space
and any deterministic algorithm
but yeah but this algorithm would have a
competitive ratio of at least k
which means that since the line is also
metric space double coverage is an
optimal online i graph
yeah and for a general metric space the
best known algorithm is work function
algorithm
which is 2k minus 1 competitive so
there's still a gap between upper and
lower bound
but there's the famous case server
conjecture which states that there
exists a k-competitive algorithm for the
caseload problem
and if we allow randomization we can
actually get very better algorithms and
there is a polylocate eyebrooking
conjunction
now let me introduce um learning
augmented online hybrid studio
and for what we will review and what we
have seen so far so we have seen an
online problem with some online input
and we have also seen a classic on an
algorithm like double coverage which
solves the problem
and this algorithm is robust because it
has this hard competitive ratio which
tells us that it won't be um
too bad compared to an
optimal offline solution for any
instance
but on the other side classic online
arguments are often performed poorly on
easy instances where it would be for
example the best idea to just move the
closest server
towards the request
but there are also other ways to solve
such problems for example we could
train some machine learned model
to predict us the online input or
predict something else
which may gives us valuable information
yeah for a possible solution
but the problem is but
yeah there's no guarantee that this
information is actually good
and this is a problem in for example
safety critical applications
and yeah this is the place where
learning augmented online algorithms
come in
and the idea is really
but they combine the best out of both
worlds
um so on one side
they use the valuable information from
machine learning models and on the other
side we want that they use um classic
robust methods
of such classic online algorithms
and we use two performance indicators to
analyze
such algorithms namely consistency and
robustness
where we say that a learning augmented
online algorithm is either consistent
if it is either competitive for having
perfect predictions
which means that
um yeah every prediction is really good
or essentially best possible with
respect to our prediction model we want
but the algorithm should also perform
really well so think of this this alpha
should be really small
and it should for example break existing
lower bounds in the online model
and on the other side we still want our
algorithm to be robust
which means that it should be better
competitive um for any prediction
um
which then says it just should be
yeah for any input its cost should not
um be much worse than
the ones of an optimal offline solution
and yeah learning augmented online
algorithms are very
um active research area right now but
almost daily they are coming new results
for various online problems
but also
for other in other areas of computer
science
um
yeah now our goal is to apply this
framework
to our problem and first of all we need
a prediction model
and we choose the prediction model
which predicts
which server we should use to serve a
certain request
so think of
the following setting when a new request
arrives
um yeah the prediction model will give
us a prediction on which server we
should use to serve to request
and yeah
this is kind of a prediction of
algorithmic actions
but
the prediction model is also compatible
with input predictions so if we have
predicted some
online input of requests
we could just compute the optimal
solution based on this prediction and
then use
this optimal solution as
prediction of our algorithmic actions
and we also show about this prediction
that these predictions are actually
packed learnable using empirical risk
minimization
so using this prediction model we can
can
design
our very first learning augmented
algorithm which is the naive one and
just follows
the predictions
yeah so we just use reproductive server
which is in circuit queen here to serve
the weakness
and since i said before it makes no
sense but one server moves by another we
can
adjust shortcut and final schedule and
moves which means that we then would
just use the
closest server of the request which is
on the same side as the predicted server
to serve the weakness
now we have seen
two algorithms for our problem
and one is follow the predictions and
the other one is starting coverage
and
yeah follow the prediction essentially
fully trusts our prediction
um because it exactly does what what it
tells us
and
we can also see that if
the prediction is correct so if we
really predict an optimal solution um
we yeah our we've just followed this
optimal solution which means that we are
one consistent
but on the other side there may be
instances and predictions
which lead to just unbounded costs
and which means that our eyewitness is
not robust
and
on the other side we've seen double
coverage so if we give double cover
which also the predicted server it would
just ignore it so it doesn't trust the
prediction at all
and
yeah since this is k competitive this
then just k consisted and k robust
now to get an so
our wish would be to get an algorithm
which kind of
uses properties of both of these
approaches um
and the idea here is that we want to
balance
how much we trust
the prediction by using speeds
and the algorithm which we come up with
and we call lambda dc is the following
so first of all
um use a hyper parameter lambda between
0 and 1
which kind of
which
expresses how much we trust the
prediction
and we then do the following
when a new request arrives we move the
server which is on the same side as the
predicted server with speed 1
and the server on the other side
with a lower speed lambda
so if we set lambda to zero this means
that we fully trust the prediction
this algorithm corresponds to
follow the prediction
and if we set lambda to 1 which means
that we
have no trust into the prediction
um our algorithm m is equal to w
coverage
so this algorithm kind of interpolates
between
follow the prediction and i will cover
which i'm using this hyper power
parameter which sets the server speeds
and
yeah what we would hope for now is
but also the performance guarantees um
for lambda dc interpolate between
difference of further prediction and
double coverage depending on lambda
and indeed we can show the following and
we will now
first look at the results for having two
servers and
and later generalized two k servers so
for having two servers we have to follow
on the site
for any lambda c one one
our algorithm is one plus lambda
consistent and one plus one over lambda
robust
which is kind of kind of what we
expected
now this theorem is nice but it only
covers six extreme cases so for example
imagine we have given some prediction
that almost every server is predicted
correctly except one
then the prediction is no longer perfect
which means that this theorem would only
give us the robustness ratio
but we would actually expect but the
algorithm on this almost perfectly
prediction
um
may performs really well
so we expect that the performance should
be close to the consistency case
and
to cover these results in between we
define the prediction error which tells
us how good our prediction is
and we have two possible definitions for
this error
first one is to just
measure the
difference in the cost of following the
prediction and the cost of an optimal
solution
and the second definition is
to sum up the differences between the
configurations of
following the prediction and the events
of a fixed optimal solution
and sum this up over all the requests
and okay using one of the prediction
errors and we get the following theorem
which states that for any lambda between
0 and 1 and lambda dc has a competitive
ratio of at most the consistency ratio
times one plus
the relative prediction error
where the relative prediction error is
just the prediction error divided by
the optimal cost of an optimal solution
um so if the prediction the error is
zero which does
um this gives the consistency ratio
and the second part of the competitive
ratio is that just the robustness ratio
now for the remaining talk
i'm going to give you an idea on how we
can
prove this theorem
and
yeah we use the usd following following
three step analysis
um in the first step we bound the cost
of our algorithm
using the consistency ratio and the cost
of following the prediction
in the second step we bound the cost of
following a prediction by the cost of an
optimal resolution and deprediction
error
and finally yeah we independently prove
the robustness ratio by comparing the
cost of the algorithm to the cost of an
optimal solution using the robust
insulation
and yeah clearly these three steps with
the other theorem
and for the general case of having k
servers you will also use the same
pre-step analysis
so the second step immediately follows
from the definition of the prediction
error
so in the following we will look at the
first first step
and then also quickly at the third step
as it is very similar to the first one
so yeah what we want to prove in the
first step is we following lemma which
stays start for any inserts i and then
any lambda between 0 and 1 because of
our algorithm are at most one plus
lambda because of following the
prediction
plus some additive constant
and our three main ingredients of this
proof
are a potential function phi
paired with the folklore lemma for
server problems which is also known as
the interlegal move technique
and this works as follows so if we want
to compute a competitive ratio between
two algorithms a and b
we
simulate both algorithms in parallel on
the same instance
and then use the potential function to
map these states of both algorithms for
any point in time to a potential
and then we have to do the following
things for every request
we first
let the i group b
serve the request
and
then we have to check if the change of
the potential function is bounded by
some constant a times because this i
would charge for serving the server
and secondly
um after b serve to request we let the
eye button a serve to request
and then we have to again to check
if we
put if we can lower bound the decrease
of the potential by some constant b
times again because we either charged
for this move
and if we
yeah
have these two bounds for both moves you
immediately get a competitive ratio
between both algorithms for the whole
instance
and our third ingredient for the proof
will be that we have yeah advanced
knowledge about ftp server positions
um depending on
what how our algorithm executes its move
okay
now let's quickly dive into the proof
so yeah denote the servers of the
algorithm by s1 and s2 and these servers
are following the bridge prediction by
x1 and x2
then we define the following potential
function which follows the classic style
of having a matching part where we
compare the positions of the algorithm
to the positions of
ftp
and scale
this up using a factor depending on
lambda
and the second part we spread this part
just
measures the distances between the
servers of the algorithm which is in the
case of having two servers just the
difference between both languages
this is our potential function
now here we apply the internal even move
technique and we assume that some
request arrives and we first let mftp
serve to request
so let's just assume that ftp uses
server x1 to serve to request
and the worst case
so we have to upper bound the change of
the potential now so in the worst case
we server s1 which is matched to
x1 in the first part of the potential
function is somewhere on the left which
means that
the distance between both um yeah just
increases by the whole cost of this move
and this immediately gives us the upper
bound
where we just have to add the
factor of the matching part of the
potential
okay
now in the second step
the algorithm serves a request
and for now assume that
the id left server is predicted as one
which means that
this server moves
the speed one towards the request
and
the other server moves the speed lambda
to the request
and we can assume by scaling but these
are the actual distances both servers
move
and yeah since we assume that s1 is
predicted and ftp already served the
request we know that the server of ftp
x1
must already be on the reference
this means that the distance between s1
and x1 due to this move
m decreases by one
but the distance between s2 and x2 may
increase by at most lambda
so this is essentially the change of the
matching part due to this move
and the change of the spreadness part is
trust but it decreases by one plus
lambda since both servers are moving
towards each other
and
yeah this one just gives um a lower
bound of one over lambda times because
of the algorithm
on the decrease of the potential
and in the final step
we can just divide these factors and get
our consistency ratio
so this was a short sketch on the proof
for the consistency case
and now we want to quickly look at the
robustness proof
so
this looks very similar here we are
comparing the algorithm to the optimal
solution
and we will almost use the same
potential function with just a slightly
different factor in front of the
matching part
and
so what really changes here is that in
second step when the algorithm serves to
request
we don't have this knowledge of which
server of the optimal solution is
actually on the request right now
so here the worst case changes to that
actually server x2 is on the request
which means that the distance between x2
and s2
decreases by lambda but the distance
between x1 and s1 may increase by 1.
and
yeah
then we could get some different
constants in dilemma
but we can still prove the robustness
ratio of one plus one over lambda
okay now let's look on the general case
yeah so we can generalize freeze precise
to having
the case of having k servers where we
have the following um
ratios so our consistency ratio will be
this alpha k expression
which is essentially yeah one plus
lambda for k equals two it's one plus
two lambda for k plus three it's one
plus two lambda plus lambda squared for
k equals four and so on
and our robustness ratio will be just
the sum of the flipped powers of lambda
from
0 to k minus 1.
and
yes so we have then the same error
dependence
of the prediction error
and
we achieve this result
right as i said before using the same
three-step analysis
but we have to use way more complex
potential functions
which still consists of a matching and
as fitness part
but for the consistency case we actually
have to use additional weights
inside the spreadness part and for the
robustness proof we have additional
server dependent weights
in the matching part
this allows us to
prove differing with technical care
okay so then let me conclude
so we have seen that there exists a
learning augmented algorithm for the
cancer problem online which is
consistent aerodependent and robust
and yeah which implements its confidence
with the prediction into the classic
double coverage algorithm using
different server speeds
and further results of our
work are
but we prove that this algorithm has a
best possible consistency robustness
trader up to a factor of two
among all memoryless eye movements that
satisfy some locality properties
and we also um
conduct
empirical experiments which show the
superior performance of our eyebrow on
real building sensors
compared to the classic double coverage
algorithm
and other learning augmented algorithms
which
work for our problem
and
the experiments
especially show
but already a
small amount of non-trust
um or small amount of justification help
to
robustify the algorithm against errors
which we can see here the green line is
just following the prediction where
lambda is zero but already setting
lambda to
um
0.1
drastically improves the performance
also for
a large relative errors
yes then
that's all i wanted to say thank you for
your attention